uh hey this also happened
many actually believe there was a local
newscast uh that refused to describe
stevenson as black i don't know if you
saw this twitter it was all over twitter
it was it turned out it was an alt-right
hoax yeah just so you know where it said
uh
it said dark white skin and jerk white
skin it's actually pretty funny that
someone created this
but and it's and it's horrible that this
this is fake news on the right we see it
on all we've seen this all around on
both sides of the spectrum
but i find more interesting that people
actually bought this when i first saw
it i wouldn't have even thought it was
fake we only know because we have a
process where we tend to double check
things and even then
occasionally we get caught but i saw it
like oh that seems like something i
would see on tv
especially after that's the problem any
terrorist attack right they're always
just avoiding as
long as they possibly can like is it
islam is it islam is it islam as it is
no no no it was islam
knew it um so i thought that was
fascinating because i tell you what i
think everyone has been there
i was mugged one time in montreal by by
a black guy
really and i i when they asked me to idm
i would do i would say
anything but that and i know people
are that's why people believe the story
they're walking around terrified to id
someone now uh
because political correctness has even
made its way into crime
yeah i'm uh on the 75 and i think that i
might
have identified steve stevens
the cleveland shooter okay sir how are
you able to identify the suspect
well uh he seems to be driving that
described ford fusion but the license
plate is covered up
uh the driver what does the driver look
uh what color is this beard black it's
very black and his
eyes brown uh maybe hazel okay sure
they're not blue
they couldn't be blue okay can you
describe his skin
color please okay whoa um
you know seems to have pretty good skin
uh pretty blemish-free seems pretty uh
take care of himself maybe use this
problem okay i need more than that what
is the skin
tone yeah you know it looks pretty toned
he probably
to ask apparently we live in a world
where we have to ask about that all you
see everything
through the prism of skin color it's a
dark white
i don't even know what that means sir
dark white
skin what take the shade of white
darken it good view shade
okay sir i'm not sure
okay the suspect is
hey if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the letters that spell out
subscribe also youtube somewhere in this
box has a recommended video for
you now i don't know what they recommend
but my guess is if you're here it's
going to be something twisted and
something you don't want your parents to
see
if you want to see the entire show from
which this clip is taken click one of
the boxes playing next to me that is the
full episode or join the mug club for
the daily show the reason the daily show
isn't on youtube
is because um well youtube doesn't like
some of the things we say